[Musik]
nach den sternen neue horizonte und
dadurch die welt auf der wir leben
verstehen
ein menschheitstraum
eine menschheit streben
[Musik]
der mond war nur das erste ziel auf der
reise in die tiefen des alls
der blick auf unseren planeten zeigt wie
verletzlich die erde ist und wie
einzigartig
die erforschung des weltraums reicht
zurück bis ins 17
jahrhundert erfindungen wie die
teleskope von galileo und newton machen
es möglich sterne und galaxien zu
entdecken die mit dem bloßen auge nicht
zu sehen sind
die erste rakete markiert den beginn der
raumfahrt und den beginn des wettlaufs
zum mond
die sowjetunion schießt den ersten
satelliten ins all und den ersten hund
sie war als erstes lebewesen im all
hündin laika eine straßen streunerin aus
moskau an bord der winzigen metallkugel
sputnik 2 wurde sie 1957 vom
sowjetischen bykow nur in den weltraum
geschossen
in der engen kapsel war lecker mit
sensoren versehen
die puls und blutdruck messen sollten
man wollte testen wie es einem säugetier
schwerelosigkeit er geht nach fünf bis
sieben stunden im all star pleiter wie
man heute war es an einem hitzeschock
den heldentod
weltweit wurde sie gefeiert zum beispiel
in japan mit der leica frisur
[Musik]
knapp drei jahre später gelang bei den
hunde versuchen der durchbruch
1960 kehrte die beiden mischlinge die lk
und strelka nach 18 erdumrundungen als
erste lebewesen heil zur erde zurück die
runde versuche beamten schnell den weg
für den ersten menschen im weltall
die amerikaner hatten im wettrennen zum
und weit abgeschlagen zurück
erst 1961 startete eine redstone rakete
in cape genommen mit an bord der erste
amélie mal eine woche umrundete er mit
6000 kilometern pro stunde die erde bei
der landung verfehlte jedoch die mercury
kapsel die geplante landes ohne um 200
kilometer
[Musik]
doch der 44 monate alt der schimpanse
hemmen überlebte die reise und vor allem
die landung mit elektroden wurden viele
daten gesammelt die aufschluss über das
leben im all geben konnten
durch diese ergebnisse konnte nun auch
die nasa ihr weltraum projekt gemini
staaten
[Musik]
die sowjetunion war zu diesem zeitpunkt
schon deutlich weiter
das auswahltraining für den ersten
menschen im weltall hatte bereits
begonnen
die wahl fällt schließlich auf ihn juri
gagarin gagarin ist der sohn einfacher
leute
der vater ist tischler die mutter
bäuerin er macht eine lehre als gießerei
techniker dann den pilotenschein schon
fünf jahre später ist er auf dem weg in
den weltraum
die sorgt jetzt haben es eilig im april
1961 sie wollen die ersten im all sein
koste es was es wolle die wostok kapsel
ist kaum erprobt eigentlich nicht
flugtauglich der 27-jährige riskiert
sein leben als um 9 uhr sieben moskauer
zeit die triebwerke zünden muss gagarin
vor allem eins durchhalten sein
raumschiff funktioniert vollautomatisch
falls der kosmonaut bewusstlos wird oder
schlimmeres
[Musik]
das raumschiff gerät ins trudeln aber
gagarin bleibt cool ich fühle mich
hervorragend berichtet ja der druck
wächst es vibriert aber ich komme klar
damit die stimmung ist gut
nach 108 minuten ist der flug zu ende
gagarin springt im schleudersitz aus der
kapsel und landet am fallschirm
die bäuerin anna tochter rover mit ihrer
enkelin erschreckend zu tode als gagarin
ihnen im raumanzug auf dem acker
entgegenkommt der cosmo nord sucht ein
telefon damit der seinen erfolg
vermelden kann
sie hatten einen lauten knall gehört und
objekte am fallschirm niedergehen sehen
sie hatten natürlich angst dass es
außerirdische sind
fürchtet euch nicht soll darin gesagt
haben ich bin einer von euch ein sowjet
mensch über radio moskau verbreitet sich
die nachricht in windeseile gagarins
mutter fällt aus allen wolken als eine
nachbarin erzählt was sie gerade im
radio gehört hat ich frage was denn sie
sagt juri und ich sage ist er mit dem
flugzeug abgestürzt und sie sagt im
weltraum und sonja fängt an zu schreien
was hat er nur getan er hat auch zwei
kleine kinder
kolumbus des kosmos jubelt ihm in
gagarin erhält für kommunistische
verhältnisse fürstliche belohnungen auto
fernseher waschmaschine und kleidung
darunter sechs paar unterhosen und
socken nur in den weltraum darf er nicht
mehr
die sowjetunion will ihr idol vor jedem
unglück bewahren jahre lang kämpft er
darum wenigstens wieder militärmaschinen
fliegen zu dürfen
kurz darauf stürzte er 1968 ab und
startete im wettlauf zum mond fliegen
die sowjets weiter vorne ihnen glück
1965 der erste weltraumspaziergang und
die erste unbemannte mondlandung 1968
holen die amerikaner auf start des
ersten bemannten apollo flugs
ganz amerika ist live beim start der
drei astronauten eisele cunningham und
kommandant scherer dabei erleichterung
bei den amerikanischen
fernsehkommentatoren und dem
kontrollzentrum von houston auch als
kurz darauf die nächste kritische
situation gemeistert wird das abstoßen
der ersten raketenstufe nach drei tagen
in der erdumlaufbahn dann der große
moment die ersten live bilder aus einer
raumkapsel
doch man sieht nur dass man nicht sieht
das bild ist verschwommen und liegt
zudem auf der seite rechts in der mitte
ist der kopf von don eissele zu sehen
und soviel kann auch der kommentator
erkennt dann braucht dringend eine rasur
das scharfstellen der kamera aber will
nicht gelingt und war acht minuten
bricht die leitung ab erfolgreicher als
dieses fernsehexperiment verläuft dann
der weitere flug und die wasserung im
atlantik nacheinander werden die
astronauten zum helikopter hoch gehievt
und kaum an bord des flugzeugträgers
empfangen die von der strapaze und einer
kräftigen erkältung gezeichneten helden
eine telefonische grußbotschaft ihres
präsidenten johnson
amerika habe mit der apollo mission
einen weiteren schritt bei der
friedlichen eroberung des weltalls getan
am 16 juli 1969 greifen die usa
zumindest nachdem und start der apollo
11 mission von eggenberg mit einem
computer an bord der einen
arbeitsspeicher von gerade mal vier
kilowatt und einer technologie die heute
denkbar einfach erscheint ungefähr bis
zum mond gekommen
und die technologiewerte in unserem
smartphone haben also die chips und der
speicherplatz und so das um ein
vielfaches höher als das was die in der
ganzen affäre hatten um bis zum mond zu
kommen also ist wirklich eigentlich irre
dass es geklappt hat
als die 3000 tonnen schwere rakete am 16
juli 1969 ihre reise ins all antritt
hält die ganze welt den atem
rund um den globus verfolgen die
menschen das spektakel für eine kurze
weile friedlich vereint durch die mond
mission für elfried worden den späteren
apollo 15 astronauten ein bewegender
moment milliarden menschen haben die
landung verfolgt und als ich mir die
massen an sah die apollo 11 zuschauten
da gab es keinerlei aggression oder
irgendetwas negatives einen eigenen
fernseher haben viele damals noch gar
nicht die menschen sammeln sich vor den
schaufenstern von elektro geschäften
veranstalten eine art open air kino auf
den bürgersteigen den historischen
moment der landung vier tage nach dem
start war niemand verpassen
für neil armstrong buzz aldrin und
michael collins ist die fast 400.000
kilometer weite reise ein
himmelfahrtskommando
neben perfekter vorbereitung brauchen
sie vor allem eines starke nerven
ich glaube einfach noch funktioniert
also für emotionen für ängste war
einfach kein platz da malt funktioniert
das risiko da hin zu fliegen war auch
enorm die wussten ja nicht ob sie
wiederkommen
das ist bei heutigen weltraummissionen
ja ganz ganz anders also ich glaube
wirklich
die mussten irgendwo das menschsein
außen vor lassen und einfach
funktionieren wie eine maschine
neil armstrongs berühmte worte als er am
21 juni 69 den mond betrat als erster
mensch nur gut zwei stunden verbringen
armstrong und aldrin außerhalb der
fehler war ihr landet auf dem mond
steigt die leiter runter läuft ein
bisschen rum und dann abflug nicht
rumhängen der beweis ist erbracht
die amerikaner haben den wettlauf mit
den sowjets zum mond gewonnen
angestachelt durch deren erfolg
1961 als dem kosmonauten juri gagarin
der erste bemannte weltraumflug gelingt
macht john f kennedy eine ansage es ist
auch so leider dass dieser wettlauf
glaube ich nötig war um überhaupt einen
menschen zum mond zu bringen
das ging ja wirklich darum wir müssen
beweisen wie sind die weltmacht und eben
nicht die sowjets und deswegen wurde da
so viel geld hineingesteckt
deswegen auf der einen seite ja toll
menschen waren auf dem mond auf der
anderen seite kam das alles aus einer
recht schwierigen konfliktreichen
situation
[Musik]
was immer passiert spiegelt die musik
wieder und die modewelt der 60er jahre
kuriose kreationen die den weg vom
laufsteg in den kleiderschrank leider
nicht geschafft haben
apollo 11 war der anfang weiterer
wissenschaftlicher missionen zum mond
und auf der erde wollen es den
astronauten schon einige privat
nachmachen 147 deutsche haben bereits
bei einer amerikanischen
fluggesellschaft einer reise zum mond
gebucht der mond war auch das ziel von
apollo 13 ohne touristen an bord
die mission begann am abend des elften
april 1970 nach der erfolgreichen
mondlandung von armstrong und aldrin
sollten nun jim hall und fällt es den
mond betreten und dort weitere
experimente durchführen
doch es kam ganz anders am frühen morgen
des 14 april kam es zu einem kurzschluss
an sauerstoff tank explodierte und
beschädigte die raumfähre odyssey so
stark dass die crew die mehrtägige reise
durchs all nicht überlebt hätte
reinhold ewald bildet alle europäischen
astronauten aus die erkenntnisse aus dem
unfall der apollo prägen seine arbeit
bis heute ganze vision war auf einmal
gescheitert die ganze mission musste
umgeplant werden und es ist eigentlich
der beginn der vertrauensvollen und und
auch in krisen engen zusammenarbeit
zwischen dem boden leitzentrum und den
astronauten im alten davon profitieren
bekanntlich heute das bodenpersonal des
kennedy space centers arbeitete
fieberhaft an der retter land lösung für
die besatzung
die astronauten von apollo 13 nutzten
die mondlandefähre areas als rettungs
pferd dafür war sie jedoch nicht
vorgesehen
die batterien für die stromversorgung
waren nur für die mondlandung gemessen
etliche systeme mussten abgeschaltet
werden um strom zu sparen
eine rettungsmöglichkeit für die
astronauten war damals nicht eingeplant
denkbar leisten also in schichten die
astronauten zu retten oder
darauf zu warten dass ein fahrzeug hoch
kommt das sind natürlich dinge die immer
wieder auch frisch mit diesem apollo 13
ereignis in erinnerung bleiben und wie
die arbeit der astronauten oben prägen
es gab ein happy end
apollo 13 ist die einzige mission die
vorzeitig abgebrochen werden musste da
alle astronauten unversehrt zu rheda
zurückkehrten bezeichnet die nasa diese
mission als erfolgreichen 4 schlag
[Applaus]
die raumfahrt verbindet auch mitten im
kalten krieg kooperation im all stand
wettlauf zu den sternen
am 17 juli 1975 dockt 225 kilometer über
der erde
eine amerikanische apollo an eine
russische sojus kapsel an
nie zuvor wurde ein solches manöver
geprobt die luftschleuse verbindet auch
2 system ein moment der verbrüderung die
us pro land kohlsuppe aus der truppe
kennen die russen amerikanische
raumfahrt kost symbolisch das
zusammenfügen zwei hälften zu einer
gedenkmedaille bald darauf war dann auch
der erste deutsche dran von baikonur
startet sigmund jähn in den weltraum
es ist der 26 august 1978 beim wettlauf
im all hat die ddr die nase vorne
der propaganda kuh ist gelungen neun
tage verbringt yen als gast auf der
raumstation saljut 6
der deutsche kosmonaut stammt aus dem
sächsischen vogtland und er passt
perfekt ins propaganda system der
kommunistischen staatsführung sohn eines
einfachen arbeiters gelernter
buchdrucker und später jagdflieger mit
studium an einer sowjetischen militär
akademie ost berlin zelebrierte seinen
helden als lebenden beweis für die
überlegenheit des kommunistischen
systems
straßen schulen und schiffe werden nach
ihm benannt jedes kind kennt ihn und yen
macht gute miene als kosmonaut zum
anfassen
schon zu lebzeiten setzt die ddr ihm ein
denkmal
erst fünf jahre später fliegt der erste
westdeutsche ulf merbold im geheimen
haben raumfahrer aus ost und west schon
lange vor dem fall der mauer kontakt man
trifft sich in jena
in den frühen 80er jahren löst das
space-shuttle-programm die alten apollo
raketen ab mit viel hoffnung waren sie
im april 1981 gestartet ganz in weiß mit
dem auftrag einen fährverkehr zwischen
erde und all zu beginnen
transporte in den weltraum sollten
erschwinglich werden die erwartungen hat
sich nie erfüllt auch die hitzekacheln
die schon beim jungfernflug abgefallen
waren blieben eine schwachstelle bis zum
ende des space shuttle flüge in den
80ern und es waren wilde ritter jenseits
der ladebucht und menschen in
raumanzügen völlig losgelöst auch für
deutsche astronauten wurden die
raumfähren zum taxi ins all als erster
vorstoss spacelab
[Musik]
auf diesen moment hat orange merbold
jahre lang gewartet 20 millionen ps
schießen ihn und seine crew ins all für
mehr wollt der höhepunkt seines lebens
ich habe jedenfalls nur die augen
aufgerissen womöglich den mund auch und
mich gefreut und gestaunt
zeit für muße bleibt wenig die arbeit an
bord ist hart täglich muss mehr wollt im
raum labor experimentieren zwölf stunden
und länger mehr bolt ist physiker und
wissenschaftstheoretiker
pflichtenkatalog alles wissenschafts
astronauten ist immer auch
die rolle meine professionelle
laborratte zusagen für die physiologie
experimente die gerade dem
gleichgewichtssinn studieren wulff mehr
wollt der erste westdeutsche im all mit
ostdeutschen wurzeln geboren und
aufgewachsen in thüringen einzelkind
eines lehrer ehepaares nach dem abitur
will mehr wollt physik studieren doch
das ddr-regime sagt nein
mehr wollte ist weder mitglied in der
fdj noch in der sed kurz vor dem
mauerbau geht dann nach westberlin seine
mutter bleibt so
meine schwiegermutter hat am 17 ich habe
immer gedacht in 17
augustin musste noch abwarten und
inzwischen kam dann die mauer
und da war es aus das schicksal meint es
nach dem studium besser beim stöbern der
stellenanzeigen trifft mehr wollt
zufällig auf eine interessante annonce
für das raumlabor spacelab werden
experimentatoren gesucht 2000 bewerber
gibt es aber mehr gold bekommt den job
mehrere jahre dauern die vorbereitungen
für den shuttle flug das aus dem
physiker mal ein astronaut werden würde
damit hatte er wollte nie gerechnet
damals konnte ich mir überhaupt nicht
vorstellen dass jemals in meiner
lebenszeit ein deutscher in den weltraum
gelangen würde schon 30 da so das war
außerhalb der vorstellungskraft als
solches überhaupt nicht zu denken
1992 flick mehr bald wieder mit der nasa
ins all zwei jahre später die dritte und
letzte reise diesmal mit den russen ziel
die raumstation ihren trotz aller
routine die angst bei ehefrau birgit
fliegt immer mit
[Musik]
insgesamt verbringt mehr bolt 50 tage im
all so viele wie kein anderer deutscher
astronaut
der moment wo man dann den fuß wieder
auf die feste erde setzen kann das ist
auch ein guter tag im wasser laufen
[Musik]
doch die raumfahrt erleidet auch immer
wieder dramatische rückschläge am 28
januar 1986 startet die challenger
millionen fernsehzuschauer in aller welt
werden zeuge des bis dahin schwersten
unglücks der bemannten raumfahrt
[Musik]
wir werden niemals vergessen
ein letztes mal haben wir sie heute
morgen gesehen wie sie sich
verabschiedet hat um die irdischen
festigen abzulegen und das antlitz
gottes zu sieben besatzungsmitglieder
der challenger kommen ums leben
zusammen mit den astronauten ist eine
ganz normale lehrerin christa mcauliffe
sie soll aus der erdumlaufbahn
unterrichten aus 11.000 bewerbern hat
die nasa christa mcauliffe für diesen
flug ausgewählt die 37 jährige
unterrichtet geschichte und ist mutter
von zwei kindern
vista war immer sehr abenteuerlustig
wollte neues ausprobieren
sie glaubte dass das weltall uns viel
lehren kann und als lehrerin wollte sie
die kinder dafür begeistern
amerika hat eine neue heldin christa
mcauliffe sie soll die erste zivilisten
einmal werden
und ich ins all fliegen dann wäre ich
euch alle in gedanken in mexiko ein
prestige-projekt für die nasa die
amerikanische raumfahrtbehörde braucht
einen öffentlichkeitswirksamen erfolg
die us-regierung plant die fördergelder
für das teure shuttle programm zu kürzen
die begleitumstände sind für christa
mcauliffe nebensächlich für sie ist
schon die vorbereitung auf die mission
ein abenteuer das man unter der decke
hängt dauert es 20 bis 30 sekunden man
fühlt sich li peter hahn
unglaublich
am morgen des staats das wetter hat
umgeschlagen es ist eiskalt am cap cana
war
immer wieder mussten in den monaten
zuvor flüge verschoben werden
90 satelliten warten auf den transport
ins all und die kunden werden ungeduldig
die nasa steht unter druck
ingenieure warnen wegen der kalten
temperaturen vor dem start die
dichtungsringe der raketen sind porös
geworden
wir konnten nicht beweisen dass es
schiefgehen würde aber wir hatten genug
daten um zu zeigen dass das risiko sehr
hoch war zu vergleichen mit russischem
roulette
als ingenieur kann sagen dass wir statt
einer kugel gleich alle sechs kugeln in
den revolver geladen hat
die nasa setzt sich über alle bedenken
gibt den start frei christa markwalder
verfolgen das geschehen vor dem
fernseher
die freude dauerte gerade einmal 73
sekunden
[Musik]
mitten im steigflug reist eine explosion
die challenger auseinander und die
besatzung in den tod
[Musik]
der frost hatte einen dichtungsring
spröde gemacht austreten da treibstoff
entzündete sich und führte zu der
katastrophe vor den augen der ganzen
welt
die eltern von christa mcauliffe
verlieren ihre tochter vor laufender
fernsehkamera
[Musik]
die besatzung der challenger ist ohne
überlebenschance
die usa traut ihr präsident beschwört
noch am selben tag einen amerikanischen
mythos
die wirken besatzungsmitglieder der
challenger hatten eine schwierige
aufgabe sie haben ihren job will land
ausgeführt wir trauern um 7 hält ein
mahnmal erinnert an die challenger
-katastrophe sechs astronauten und eine
lehrerin verlieren ihr leben
sie sind die ersten die im shuttle den
tod finden sie werden nicht die letzten
beiden
[Musik]
es ist der erste februar 2003 als der
us-präsident von seinem landsitz in camp
david zurück nach washington alt das
space shuttle columbia ist abgestürzt
fünf stunden nach dem unglück wendet
sich george hw bush an die nation
liebe landsleute dieser tag brachte eine
schreckliche nachricht und großem
schmerz für unser land um 9 uhr hat das
raumfahrtzentrum in houston den kontakt
zur raumfähre columbia verloren
kurze zeit später waren trümmer zu sehen
am himmel über texas
wir haben columbia verloren es gibt
keine überlebenden
dies sind die bilder die seit stunden
wieder und wieder über amerikas
fernsehschirme laufen einige kleine
teile fliegen weg dann ist der rest der
stolzen welt raumfähre columbia nur noch
ein glühend dabei ich saß gerade vor dem
computer und war auf der nasa webseite
ich wusste das space shuttle sollte bei
uns vorbeikommen und wollte gerade zur
tür raus zu gucken
dann hörte ich diese riesige explosion
und dann donnerte es etwa 45 sekunden
ich stand vor meiner tür auf der veranda
und guckte nach oben und es war genau
über uns columbia war zu diesem
zeitpunkt 25.000 kilometer schnell
der moment der bei jeder raum mission
kritisch ist der wiedereintritt in die
erdatmosphäre
der shuttle ist aber eine
außentemperatur von 1600 grad ausgesetzt
bis zu dem unglück hat er es keine
anzeichen gegeben dass etwas falsch
läuft
16 minuten später hätte columbia landen
sollte das ist ein sehr schwieriger tag
für uns alle
viele von uns standen draußen an der
landebahn um ihre triumphale rückkehr zu
feiern
nach ihrer 16 tägigen mission sie haben
im funkkontakt der letzten tage erlebt
dass sie geliebt haben was sie taten und
dass sie es für richtig hielten
die wissenschaft voranzubringen
[Musik]
der letzte weckruf heute morgen von der
bodenstation
die antwort aus dem all
guten morgen houston wir machen uns
fertig für einen tollen tag
wir hatten eine tolle zeit hier oben und
freuen uns wieder nach hause zu kommen
dann später der letzte funkspruch die
bodenstation
wir haben der letzten daten nicht
bekommen
columbia und dann nichts mehr
16 minuten vor der geplanten landung der
colombia und es ist gespenstisch still
im kontrollzentrum von houston und sie
versuche es noch einmal
doch die einzige antwort ist das
rauschen des shuttle radios keiner der
sieben astronauten meldet sich direktor
leroy cain ahnt dass etwas nicht stimmt
melden sich die hydraulische systeme
zurück fragt er
nein wir haben auch das buch getriebe
verloren sie antworten nicht mehr
ich melde dass vier temperaturregler
ausgestattet sind
das system spinnt wir haben die daten
verloren
dann hätten wir ein radarbild haben
müssen
schon vor einer minute
der funkkontakt ist abgebrochen und die
columbia gerade explodiert diese neuen
bilder aufgenommen aus einem
hubschrauber zeigen wie der space
shuttle in viele teile zerbricht und
schließlich abstürzte
in diesem moment erfährt der chef der
bodenzentrale dass es dafür augenzeugen
gibt und er weiß leroy cain dass es
vorbei ist schließt die türen sagt er zu
seinen leuten aus der angst ist
gewissheit geworden es ist der moment in
dem auch ein nasa man mal weint statt
der landung wird nun die katastrophe
organisiert keine telefonate aus diesem
raum keine gespräche auf diesen
leitungen hier keine datenweitergabe es
gehen keine übertragungen rein oder raus
so kurz vorm ziel ist alles zu ende was
bleibt ist die bergung der trümmer modi
können sie bestätigen dass rund um
dallas leute mobilisiert worden sind um
uns zu helfen
es ist der tag den der nasa-ingenieur
immer gefürchtet hat kann jetzt nur noch
beten für die crew und für ihre familien
das space shuttle programm ist nicht
mehr zu halten zu teuer zu anfällig zu
gefährlich
[Musik]
am 8 juli 2011 startet zum letzten mal
ein space shuttle
es ist die atlantis eine ära geht zu
ende doch jedes ende hat allen anfang
endet mit den plänen die mil aufzugeben
entstand ein internationales projekt der
superlative
die international space station css das
größte technologieprojekt aller zeiten
seit dem jahr 2000 arbeiten und forschen
hier wissenschaftler aus aller welt und
amerikaner und russen hand in hand die
welt wg in 400 kilometern höhe
[Musik]
für deutschland war alexander gerst auf
der iss und sorgte mit seinen bildern
und filmen auf den sozialen netzwerken
für einen regelrechten boom
der astronaut als idol
[Musik]
liebe enkelkinder ihr seid noch nicht
auf der welt und ich weiß nicht ob ich
jemals treffen werde
im moment sieht es so aus als ob wir
euch den planeten nicht gerade im besten
zustand hinterlassen werden
ich hoffe sehr für euch dass wir noch
die kurve kriegen und ein paar dinge
verbessern können
kurz vor seiner rückkehr zur erde sendet
alexander gerst an der botschaft an
seine enkelkinder
der clip wurde hunderttausendfach
abgerufen sein blick auf unseren
planeten berührt seine arbeit 400
kilometer über der erde hat viele
menschen fasziniert
interessant ist außerdem ist anders
aussehen kann die dinge recht einfach
und prägnant erklären dass er sich auch
intensiv hier beteiligt hat von oben hat
sich während von oben gemeldet und hatte
einen sich irgendwo hier eingemischt und
hat mit schulen interviews gemacht
alexander gerst letzte mission startete
am 6 juni 2018
kein deutscher war bis jetzt länger im
all als der promovierte geophysiker aus
baden württemberg über 350 tage
mit 26 millionen ps startet alexander
klaws zu assassins an
[Musik]
das traum geht in erfüllung schon als
kind ist gast ein entdecker typ ein
junge der allen löcher in den bauch
fragte zb captain future damals gesehen
ist zwar immer einer meiner
kindheitshelden der captain's ramisch
eines raumschiffes der ist unbekannte
erkundet hat aber ich habe mich damit
nicht zufrieden stellen lassen für mich
war das nie genug sich irgendwas
vorzustellen wie es mal sein könnte
sondern ich wollte wissen wie es ist
6000 trainingsstunden musste gerste im
vorfeld absolvieren
davon mehr als 600 unter wasser das
sechsfache der erdbeschleunigung musste
er aushalten minutenlang
überlebenstraining bei minus 27 grad für
den fall einer notlandung
all das vorbereitungen für das leben in
der wahrscheinlich unwahrscheinlichsten
maschine die die menschheit je gebaut
hat hat gestern mal gesagt so groß wie
ein fußballfeld zieht die iss mit 28.000
kilometern pro stunde um die erde
auf dem außenposten der menschheit
forschen seit 20 jahren astronauten um
das leben auf der erde besser zu machen
zum beispiel mit dem projekt ikarus
astronauten montieren für dieses projekt
an antenne hochriskant außen an der iss
die empfängt gps signale von tieren und
diese signale können er vor erdbeben und
vulkanausbrüchen waren faszinierend auch
die experimente mit wasser weniger
forschungs nutzen dafür etwas fürs auge
in der schwerelosigkeit bildet das
schwebende kugeln stadt runterzufallen
damit die knochen und muskeln der
astronauten nicht abbauen stehen täglich
zwei stunden sport an
auf der erde helfen diese daten neue
medikamente gegen muskeln und knochen
krankheiten zu entwickeln
doch der nutzen des fliegenden labors
wird auch von experten in frage gestellt
deutschland kostet das 180 millionen
euro haben wir eigentlich immer wieder
auch in verschiedenen studien
nachgewiesen dass der der nutzen
eigentlich eher ein nutzen ist er nicht
im wissenschaftlichen oder im
ökologischen bereich sondern nutzen ist
er im bereich der völkerverständigung
für die wissenschaft gibt es andere wege
auch durchaus kostengünstige wege diese
experimente und diese forschung
durchzuführen
für die meisten aber bleibt die iss ein
faszinosum auch dank alexander gerst er
hat es gut verstanden sich und seine
arbeit in szene zu setzen
oft kamen größe per twitter oder er
begeisterte beim live schalten zu
ansonsten möchte ich ihnen nur sagen
dass ich zweimal die freude hatte die
iss über der uckermark vorbei fliegen zu
sehen wir haben deshalb auch extra wenn
wir über die uckermark geflogen sind die
ausrichter angelassen es schön dass es
geklappt hat was bei den meisten von
alexander gerst missionen hängen
geblieben ist seine atemberaubenden
bilder seine sorgen um den planeten aber
auch die begeisterung für die schönheit
des universums
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zuerst es gibt es seit 2020 neue raum
verbinden boeing ist in der finalen
testphase ihres damals und verfehlte bei
einem ersten test de ss
die brücke
die space sex ist mit ihrer crew dragon
am 30 mai 2020 bereits erfolgreich
gestartet
die astronauten bauch bänken und paris
orly verabschieden sich von ihren
familien eine letzte umarmung auf
distanz pioniere sind sie an diesem tag
dabei sind sie veteranen mit dem
spaceshuttle waren sie schon auf der
raumstation iss
nun geht es mit der kapsel eines
privatunternehmens hoch mit der idee von
elon musk
dies ist der höhepunkt eines traumes der
wahl wird so real
wenn du mich damals zum beginn von
spacex gefragt hättest ob dies passieren
würde hätte ich gesagt 0,1 prozent
chance passend im tesla rüber zur rampe
nach jahren des trainings und wochen in
corona quarantäne cinterion bänken am
ziel
wenn wir uns als absolventen der
pilotenschule was als traumjob hätten
wünschen dürfen dann genau dies ein
brandneues raumfahrzeug zu fliegen
es ist ein faszinierendes wgl es ist
eine kapsel viel kleiner als ein shuttle
aber state-of-the-art anschnallen für
die premiere
russland die usa und china verlieren ihr
monopol nun bringen auch
privatunternehmen menschen soll die nasa
will mehr von dieser kommerzialisierung
des weltraums dieses geschäftsmodell
einer öffentlich privaten partnerschaft
senkt die kosten
es ermöglicht uns auf den mond zu
fliegen und dort auch zu bleiben das
alles mit dem ziel auf den mars zu
kommen um 15 uhr 22 ortszeit greifen die
amerikaner wieder nach den sternen
nachdem sie neun jahre mit der
sojus-kapsel der russen fliegen mussten
das kratzt am ego entsprechen lässt auch
der präsident beim start dabei große
symbolik tut gut in schweren zeiten für
das land echtes talent echt genial
niemand macht das wie wir toll dieses
programm wieder zu haben und dass die
crew dragon kapsel unterwegs richtung
raumstation iss
beim transport von fracht haben sich
rakete und kapsel bereits bewährt nun
befördert sie menschen das risiko ist
enorm groß bei jedem raumflug
mitmenschen aber ganz besonders bei
diesen es ist der zweite flug dieser
kapsel
aber der erste mit menschen an bord die
mission ist ein erfolg unspektakulär ist
jeder an tritt zurück in die
erdatmosphäre
die zukunft der raumfahrt geht weit über
die usa hinaus
die pas pace ist das ziel zuerst der
mond dann der maas die neuen raumfähren
dafür sind die orion entwickelt in
europa und das starship von spacex beide
noch in der entwicklungsphase
[Musik]
helga und so war gehören zu den wenigen
auserwählten die demnächst zum mond
fliegen kann
bald sollen sie den mond umkreisen im
dienst der wissenschaft
dabei geht es um die frage wie wird die
strahlung im hals auf den menschlichen
körper
die zukunft wird sein
langzeitaufenthalte auf dem mond
langzeitaufenthalte im interplanetaren
raum das ist auch der flug zum mars der
aufenthalt auf der oberfläche des mars
ist die rückkehr und dann bewegen wir
uns auch in strahlungsdosen die wir so
für menschen jetzt auf der
internationalen raumstation zum beispiel
nie gehabt haben
die strahlenbelastung gilt als eines der
größten probleme für menschen im
weltraum
für frauen ist sie wohl noch
gefährlicher als für männer deshalb
stecken im inneren von helga und sogar
geräte die unterschiedliche strahlend an
unterschiedlichen stellen lassen
so ausgerüstet werden sie zwei der
begehrten plätze der orion einnehmen
das amerikanische raumschiff mit
europäischer antriebstechnik soll zum
mond fliegen zunächst unbekannt doch
schon in wenigen jahren könnten wieder
menschen auf unserem himmlischen
nachbarn landen
[Musik]
dann wäre es natürlich auch schön wenn
wieder wie also bei der letzten emission
ein ausgebildeter wissenschaftler auf
dem mond wäre die dann dort vor ort dann
als wissenschaftler auch forschung
betreiben könnte auf eine solche
forschungsreise bereitet sich der
deutsche esa astronaut matthias maurer
vor
eine seiner letzten trainerstation
norwegen auf den lofoten ähnelt das
gestein den gebirgen des mannes dem
astronauten auf den mond und später auf
den mars geschickt werden dann soll die
natürlich die richtigen gesteinsproben
einsammeln weil nur diese guten
gesteinsproben helfen den
wissenschaftlern die fragestellungen zu
beantworten die wir oben auf dem und
erklären wollen
eine führt zum ursprung von erde und
mond forscher vermuten dass ein maß
großer himmelskörper auf die frühe erde
breiter aus den trümmern entstand der
mond er blieb unverändert während sich
die erde immer weiter verformte die
oberfläche des mondes ist wie ein archiv
das die frühe erdgeschichte gespeichert
hat
all das was wir dort sehen also diese
einschläge und die altstadt skater die
wir erzählen haben
aufgezeichnet wie die das bombardement
von körpern im frühen sonnensystem
gewesen ist und natürlich auf der erde
deshalb möchten wir zurückkehren andorf
auf dem mond soll uns helfen unseren
nächsten nachbarn und uns selbst zu
verstehen und dann aufzubrechen in die
weiten des universums
irgendwann werden wir einen weiteren
riesenschritt zum mars machen
das wird uns nicht viel bringen außer
einem grund die technologien für die
hin- und rückreise zu entwickeln
wir werden diese technologie
weiterentwickeln müssen um irgendwann zu
einem ort zu gelangen der gut für uns
ist nicht in unserem sonnensystem
das liegt weit in der zukunft aber man
fängt immer mit dem ersten schritt an
und der mond war der erste schritt vom
mond hinaus in die tiefen des alls ein
traum von star trek der schon bald
realität werden
[Musik]